the Joe Rogan experience and it
correctly from wrong but they do make an
effort to not go into tourist areas into
resort areas and the cartel well this is
the thing because they own it or they
have investments in it that's why so
like if you go to Punta Mita or
something like that you think they have
investments it's in their best interest
of have things you know quiet yeah a lot
of people so I do a lot of training as
for do a lot of classes stuff like that
travel safety things and people are
amazed with some of the cases that I
bring a fourth that they think they're
gonna get abducted or drugged by the
cartels and some discotheque somewhere
down there yeah
and it's usually American Americans
traveling down there doing their thing
down there against other Americans and
then coming back up
it's a perfect deal crime oh really yeah
there's low did not happen with a guy
who killed his girlfriend down there
yeah there's a case of something like
that where in the Caribbean if that
makes sense like there would be a good
way to get rid of some of those cases
made a mistake
the cartel got her I miss her so much
man a lot of the a lot of the the drug
gangs that happen there down there
during that Spring Break type era that
type of timeframe mm-hmm it's always
Americans against America it's kind of
doing this and people think it's the
cartels are drugging people
no it's sometimes it's Americans taking
advantage of the whole being in the
foreign land type thing I was staying
with my family and put Tomita at the
four seasons and we we they we have
these golf carts and you can take the
golf carts out of the resort and they're
like can we take the golf carts to the
town they're like sure go ahead we leave
the resort the first thing you see is
military vehicle armored with soldiers
standing at the border of the [ __ ]
Four Seasons with machine guns on the
roof of this thing standing there ready
to rock case anything goes down yeah
they're probably waiting for the rival
cartel guys to come through so again a
lot of these people who legitimize their
businesses your years back so a lot of
the money and those in those resorts
probably probably trace it back to
cartel interests Wow so it's just deep
it permeates the entire culture yes it's
it's it's it's part of the business my
model and you know a lot of the money
that moves around down there there's
something so a relationship with it
Jesus Christ man it's kind of feel for
you for a guy like you who gave your
blood sweat and tears and was a part of
trying to stop this it must feel so
strange to watch this
nightmare sort of play out you know so
being up here and most of my friends for
some reason I have attracted so many
like Marines to my life I don't know why
yeah a lot I have a few see old friends
and most mostly just crazy marine guys
and I've been learning about what post
conflict is post conflict or being a
veteran a combat marinates is through
them through their eyes mm-hmm
you know things like post-traumatic
stress disorder and and and stuff like
that is TBI are things that I didn't
even know we're a thing till they came
up here no one talks about in Mexico
that doesn't exist it's not you know
it's not discussed know you if you go
into a situation and you you know do
something somewhere you get a few days
off you know that's about it and come
back to work Wow and medical wise you
know you've like I've been discovering
all these issues I have from that
experience down there and it's like what
kind of issues yeah my nose is pretty as
pretty has been spread substantially
destroyed and might have a few you know
head injuries and you know I didn't know
what they were you know I just it stress
you know where on the body it's my age
I'm 36 I shouldn't be feeling like this
you know and through them they kind of
pointed me and like you probably have
this because this is what I had because
I was in Iraq it's like I wasn't in Iraq
I might as well been in Iraq well that's
that's the thing that the the and and
also you guys recognize your veterans
you know not you know not enough not
enough there's no such thing as a
veteran down there you know somebody
somebody what am I
[ __ ] friends marine friends I gave me
a Mexican drug war veteran hat because
all those guys had their own hats you
know so I think a Mexican drug war
better than hat and had an eagle you
know being strangled by a snake
and it was pretty funny you know but it
but it made me realize how there's a
bunch of guys down in Mexico that
amazing things and they're getting a
recognition because it's a war that they
deny right there's nothing happened
there's no war happening this is so good
of the cartels and but there's no war
you know even the current president said
you know this is the end of the drug war
because I said so kind of thing oh so
there's no war anymore okay because why
the bore is over
[Applause]